[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo le magazine des temps forts de
l'actualité de la semaine à l'assemblée
et au sénat avec à mes côtés au
rayonnement fini bonjour oriane ont
gentiment est notre invité cette semaine
et sébastien chenu député du nord et
porte parole du rassemblement national
bonjour à vous bonjour et cette semaine
le parlement examiner les mesures
d'urgence décidées par emmanuel macron
pour répondre à la crise des gilet jaune
les ministres agnès buzyn et muriel
pénicaud sont venus les défendre
mercredi devant les parlementaires
là ces mesures ont été votées en fin de
semaine par le parlement un vote qui n'a
pas empêché de vifs débats
et c'est dans ce contexte que le
parlement a définitivement adopté le
budget 2010 9,1 nombre d'amendements
record un budget marqué par la crise des
gilet jaune
il comprend des baisses d'impôts et de
dépenses publiques mais le déficit
repasse au dessus de la barre des 3%
l'attentât de strasbourg a relancé une
nouvelle fois la polémique sur les
fichiers s objet de critiques
récurrentes sur l'art efficacité cette
semaine un rapport sur le sujet a été
remis par le sénat et pour les sénateurs
c'est un instrument à préserver
cette semaine le parlement a donc voté
les mesures d'urgence répondant à la
crise des gilet jaune alors re déroulant
le fil de cette adoption dans l'urgence
mercredi après la présentation du texte
en conseil des ministres agnès buzyn et
muriel pénicaud sont venu le défendre
devant les parlementaires
à l'image de ce texte bâti dans la
précipitation n'a pu voir quelques
hésitations de la part du gouvernement
notamment sur la question du financement
le résumé de leur audition devant le
sénat et signé quentin calmer c'est dans
l'urgence que c'est d'organiser cette
audition
seulement quelques heures après la
présentation en conseil des ministres du
projet de loi gilet jaune
il s'agit pour le parlement de s'emparer
du texte mais depuis une semaine une
confusion règne sur plusieurs mesures
promises par l'exécutif et même les
ministres mercredi
on semblait parfois hésiter cela
représente moins de 22 1580 euros
et là j'ai un doute si ses avants après
65 ans parce qu'effectivement le même
temps avec finalement quatre axes dans
ce texte premier point examiné en
urgence par le parlement
la hausse du smic 200 euros annoncés par
emmanuel macron c'est en fait la prime
d'activité qui va être revalorisée à
partir du 5 février 2019
nous avons fait un choix qui est le
suivant c'est le bonus individuels de la
prime d'activité qui va être augmenté de
90 euros
je vous rappelle que dans le père fss
nous avions actes et 30 euros
d'augmentation donc nous passons à 90
euros
cela permet concrètement de toucher tous
les travailleurs rémunérés au smic ou un
peu plus qui vivent au sein de foyers
modestes qui vivent autour du smic
seconde mesure l'annulation de la hausse
de la csg pour les retraités touchant
jusqu'à 2000 euros par mois
une mesure qui va coûter 1,5 milliard
d'euros
troisième article du projet de loi gilet
jaune l'exonération de cotisations
sociales des heures supplémentaires des
heures sup qui n'entreront pas dans
l'assiette fiscale du calcul de l'impôt
sur le revenu aujourd'hui
on estime à peu près 9 millions les
personnes susceptibles d'avoir faire des
heures supplémentaires au secteur privé
c'est-à-dire un salarié sur deux c'est
très important et ce sera une mesure qui
aura donc un impact très important en
terme en termes de pouvoir d'achat
dernier axe les primes exceptionnelles
versées par les entreprises et exonéré
de charges sociales et d'impôt sur le
revenu avec un plafond de 1000 euros
elles concerneront les salariés touchant
jusqu'à 3600 euros mensuels des mesures
qu'il va s'agir maintenant de compenser
dans un second temps dans le budget de
l'état
mais l'exécutif entend se donner du
temps un projet de loi de finances
rectificative ne sera présenté qu'au
printemps
ces médecins chanel ce sont des mesures
d'urgence 1 qui ont été présentées pour
répondre à cette crise des gilet jaune
on a vu dans ce sujet
les hésitations des ministres devant les
parlementaires est ce que vous diriez
que l'urgence a entraîné une certaine
impréparation
non mais ce gouvernement bricole la
france je crois qu'on est en train de
s'en apercevoir et non pas de cap
ils ne savent pas où ils nous emmènent
ils ont cherché à gagner du temps et
c'est la triste réalité il n'y a aucune
solution pérenne
aucune solution face aux trois crises
que nous avons découvert cette crise de
la répartition sociale des richesses
celle du pouvoir d'achat cette crise de
la répartition spatiale des richesses
celle de l'aménagement du territoire et
puis cette crise de la représentativité
on à du bricolage
on a des mesures que certaines sont
sympathiques certaine nous les avons
nous même proposé et défendu le
gouvernement en tout cas sa majorité la
république en marche sur les heures
supplémentaires avaient voté contre jean
thomas dame pénicaud qui argumentent et
qui dit ces heures supplémentaires
défiscalisées
elles vont permettre un vrai gain de
pouvoir d'achat elle nous a dit
exactement l'inversé
lorsqu'on l'avait proposé en fait ce
gouvernement navigue à vue bricole la
france est bien entendu ne solutionne
rien de façon pérenne et bien à g
ces mesures d'économie d'urgence
économique et social répond-t-elle à
l'urgence économique et social du pays
n'ont pas du tout pas du tout parce que
ce sont de petites mesures elles sont
souvent injuste sur la prime d'activité
par exemple j'entendais la bad amusé à
nous dire vous parlez de bonus
individuels elle bonus individuels on a
bien compris ce que j'ai voulu dire
c'est qu'en fait tout les gens qui
touchent le smic ne toucherons pas cette
hausse de la prime d'activité les faits
une femme qui est mariée par exemple et
qui fait un temps partiel et bien si son
conjoint son mari
gagne plus que le smic elle c'est fini
elle n'aura pas de hausse de sa prime
d'activité même si elle même est en
dessous du smic donc par conséquent on a
bien compris tout ça ne solutionne pas
et les français vont se réveiller avec
une terrible gueule de bois vous êtes
très critique sur sa mesure votée au
parlement
non mais nous les avons voté parce que
tout ce qui peut donner quelque chose
aux français tout cet argent qu'on leur
vole qu'on leur pique tout au long de
l'année
si on peut le rendre un peu tant mieux
il faut le faire mais sincèrement quand
même que c'est tant mieux non mais
d'accord des lumières de pouvoir d'achat
rendu aux ménages d'accord ça ne
solutionne rien moi je suis d'accord les
nous on a une cohérence les la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires on l'a proposé on l'a
voté les députés en marchant trouvé ça
horrible à l'époque et ont refusé de la
voter là maintenant ils nous disent mais
finalement c'était formidable
donc on va pas dire le contraire de ce
qu'on a dit je laisse ça aux
républicains qui soutenaient cette
mesure sous sarkozy mais qui hélas n'ont
pas voulu la voter on l'a vote par
cohérence mais on sait très bien tout ça
ne solutionnera rien on sait très bien
que le gouvernement
il a cherché à gagner du temps et que le
l'effet boomerang va être terrible je
crois qu'en tant vos critiques sur la
prime d'activité choisi pour augmenter
le smic qu'aurait-il fallu faire d'après
vous
nous on avait proposé quelque chose qui
était l'augmentation des petits salaires
et des petites retraites c'est à dire
tout ce qu'ils avaient à peu près à
moins de 1500 euros tout ce qui était à
moins de 1500 euros net mensuel de 200
euros et on le financé par une taxe à
l'importation 3%
on avait fait cette proposition dont qui
était budgété qui était cadré le
gouvernement n'a pas voulu parce qu'il a
une idéologie pour lequel taxes et des
produits à l'importation
bah ça ne rentre pas dans son cursus
idéologique il y est hostile
mais nous on peut on considérer que ça
c'était une mesure pérenne qui donnait
tout de suite un pouvoir d'achat
supplémentaire aux français et aux
françaises qui avaient moins de 1500
euros par mois qu'ils soient en retraite
ou qu'ils soient actifs cette
proposition bien entendu a été rejetée
par en marche sur le financement de ces
mesures on parle d'un chef de 10
milliards que vous y voyez plus car sur
la manière dont elles vont être financés
non et d'ailleurs ce débat budgétaire de
la part réglée
vous savez il ya des sources de
financement dans notre pays on pourrait
parler de l'évasion fiscale on pourrait
parler de la fraude sociale
on pourrait parler du coût des
migrations on pourrait parler du coût de
l'union européenne mais tout ça le
gouvernement ne veut pas y toucher tant
il va pas chercher le financement de ces
mesures
de ce côté là en réalité quand ils
augmentent est la prime d'activité qui
valent à financer la prime une activité
parce que c'est une aide sociale la
prime d'activité elle donc financé par
l'impôt des français c'est pas du tout
quelque chose qui économiquement
a du sens en termes de pouvoir d'achat
donc il ya d'autres façons de pouvoir
construire des équilibres budgétaires
dans ce pays mais ça veut dire changer
de politique et doit finir nous a dit
ignorer plagne a pas de tournant social
aurait fallu une hausse clair et net du
smic ont des fois autre chose on défend
200 euros de plus pour petits salaires
et petites retraites pas la hausse du
smic on a trouvé une autre capacité
augmentée pouvoir d'achat des français
financée par une taxe de 3% en
importations c'est ce dispositif que
nous soutenons alors après cette
audition au sénat mercredi soir
l'assemblée a voté le texte en
commission des affaires sociales et
jeudi place à l'examen dans l'hémicycle
du palais bourbon le texte là aussi a
été largement adopté 142 voix pour 8
contre et 46 abstentions est les débats
ont cependant rappelé qu'au delà de la
volonté partagée sur tous les bancs de
l'hémicycle de ne pas faire obstacle à
l'adoption de ces mesures est bien
l'heure n'était pas à l'union nationale
résumé signée alice rouge avec quatre
articles seulement mais deux cent trente
neuf amendements et l'opposition qui
crie à la censure
nombre de nos amendements également qui
porte sur le sujet ont été écartés et je
crains donc qu'au lieu d'un débat nous
ayons un débarras écartée car hors sujet
répond le président de l'assemblée ces
amendements ne présente de l'or aucun
lien le débat est muselée la majorité au
garde-à-vous selon christian jacob qui à
plusieurs reprises interpelle les
députés la république en marche
vous avez été collée au pilori vous
n'avez pas le droit de parler d'ailleurs
vous respectez votre droit on ne vous
entend pas vous êtes incapable de
défendre le moindre amendement
si vous avez envie de débattre prenez la
parole une majorité sourde qui n'a pas
pris la mesure de la colère c'est le mot
clé des discussions la colère est
immense colère de coller racoleur la
colère colère cette colère une colère
pas prête de s'arrêter selon la france
insoumise qui s'opposent notamment au
retour de la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires
vous pensez qu'avec quatre mesures et un
grand débat vous allez régler un
problème de cette dimension pour donner
une miette de pouvoir vivre à la
majorité de la population vous avez
ressusciter les mesures du vieux monde
en l'occurrence celle de l'ère sarkozy
bref tout absolument tout plutôt que de
partager les richesses et le travail
d'autant disent toutes les oppositions
que ce texte n'est pas
conforme aux promesses des manuels
macron les français découvrent que le
président de la république une fois de
plus leur a menti
droit dans les yeux il est regrettable
que la mise en oeuvre de ces mesures ne
soient pas à l'identique des mots qu'il
a prononcé devant plusieurs millions de
français cessé aujourd'hui à contrecoeur
ce qui nous amène n'ont pas voté
favorablement ces mesures mais à nous
abstenir parce que vous avez menti vous
avez trompé les français
abstention de la quasi-totalité des
républicains comme des socialistes la
france insoumise et les communistes ont
voté contre
mais le projet de loi finalement été
adoptée après plus de treize heures de
débats
sébastien chenu l'éviction de dizaines
d'amendements des oppositions pour motif
d'inconstitutionnalité vous ont-elles
une décision légitime du président de
l'assemblée nationale où une décision
politique
on sait très bien que ce que cherche ce
président cette majorité ce gouvernement
c'est à une passionnée l'opposition nous
n'avons eu nous les députés du
rassemblement national aucune minute 0
temps de parole dans ce débat 0,11
million d'électeurs pour une le pen aux
élections présidentielles égal zéro
temps de parole mais oui d'accord
enfin au titre de député dans un script
je rappelle que dans certains débats on
a parfois cinq minutes quelques miettes
0 top parole pour les députés du
rassemblement national
est-ce que c'est pas ça le scandale
est-ce que c'est pas l'incapacité à
véritablement affronter le débat alors
c'est on a du souci à se faire sur leur
grand débat national parce que si même à
l'assemblée nationale ils sont pas
capables d'entendre des élus de la
république
qu'est ce que ça va être dans les
régions dans les départements lorsqu'il
fut mal absolu
on a bien compris que le but du
gouvernement c'était de faire taire les
français n'a entendu pendant ces débats
jean luc mélenchon a appelé un noël au
rond-point manière de dire qu'il faut
que le mouvement des gilet jaune de se
poursuivre que dites vous moi j'ai
toujours fait confiance au gilet jaune
depuis le début on a eu la même ligne
nous n'avons pas donné de direction au
gilet jaune ils font ce qu'ils veulent
nous soutenons leurs revendications et
nous soutenons les problèmes sur
lesquels ils mettent le doigt les gilets
jaunes feront ce qu'ils voudront encore
une fois je le dis d'ailleurs à peu près
depuis cinq semaines assurant qu'on pose
la question les gilets jaunes feront ce
qu'ils voudront
ce sont des citoyens responsables
en revanche ce qui devrait se réveiller
avant un autre c'est ce gouvernement qui
nous construit un budget d'arnaqueurs et
baratineur qui ment aux français
emmanuel macron qui devant 23 millions
de français racontent n'importe quoi
puisque lorsqu'on traduit son discours
dans la réalité budgétaire
le compte n'y est pas c'est un budget
qui fait place encore une fois aux
copains emmanuel macron rien sur la
taxation des salaires des dirigeants du
cac 40
une suppression d'une taxe pour les pour
les grands médias de 50 millions d'euros
et puis on découvre qu'il ya des
millions de fausses cartes de ces kits
de faux numéros de sécurité sociale qui
coûte 20 milliards aux français par an
est sûre ça il ya rien du tout pour
écouter ce gouvernement se moque du
monde ce sont des arnaqueurs ce sont des
bricoleurs à vous parler du budget on va
justement en parler plus en détail c'est
notre deuxième thème le budget 2010 neuf
il a été définitivement adoptée après
trois mois de débats et de nombreux
rebondissements le budget 2010 9 a été
adoptée définitivement à l'assemblée
nationale jeudi son parcours a été
mouvementée jusqu'à la fin puisque en
milieu de semaine l'exécutif a hésité à
retirer une partie des premières mesures
promises par le premier ministre dans la
crise des gilet jaune matignon s'est
finalement ravisé mais les oppositions
en ont profité pour dénoncer un
gouvernement qui ne tient pas ses
promesses en particulier sur le smic le
résumé est signée stéphanie de coeur qui
parmi les salariés au smic touchera
vraiment sentent euro de plus à la fin
du mois comme la prime d'activité est
versée en fonction des revenus du foyer
le calcul n'est pas si simple les
députés de l'opposition ont des doutes
sur l'engagement du président de la
république
combien parmi les cinq millions de
foyers
combien de foyers vont bénéficier des 90
euros permis parce que 2,675 milliards
ça permet pas 90 euros par foyer fiscaux
tels qu'annoncés par le prêt dans la
pluie engagement tenu rétorque le
ministre du budget est-ce que les gens
qui sont au spi que demain vous voir 100
euros d'augmentation la réponse est oui
une revalorisation de 90 euros d'après
d'activité et nous avons 20 euros de
revalorisation du smic
ça fait donc effectivement grosso modo à
quelques euros près entre 110 euros
d'augmentation pour les gens qui sont au
smic
les députés ont définitivement débloquer
deux milliards d'euros supplémentaires
pour la prime d'activité creusant un peu
plus le déficit c'est une augmentation
puissante des déficits publics puisqu'on
passe la barre fonds symbolique symboles
ont peu d'importance mais ça compte
quand même des 100 milliards d'euros et
c'est probablement pas fini
les hausses de taxes sur les carburants
à l'origine du mécontentement des gilets
jaunes ont bien disparu du budget de 8
l'extension du chèque énergie du chèque
carburant et la surprime à la conversion
annoncée en novembre sont maintenues
malgré les cafouillages à matignon mardi
après midi
enfin contre l'avis du gouvernement les
députés en supprimer l'avantagé fiscal
pour les biocarburants à base d'huile de
palme pour moi le d'opale ne sera jamais
quelque chose de durable ne serait ce
que par son transport et ne serait ce
que pour la déforestation qu'un la pause
d'autre part et certains collègues l'ont
rappelé ici nous avons tout ce qu'il
faut en france et en europe pour les
filières d'avoir un carburant pardon
c'est leur agrocarburants au
biocarburant donc je ne vois pas la
nécessité de faire venir du bout du
monde de l'huile de palme pour faire des
biocarburants pour calmer la grogne des
forces de l'ordre les députés ont voté
une prime exceptionnelle 300 euros pour
cent dix mille policiers et militaires
mobilisés par le mouvement des gilet
jaune coût de la mesure 33 millions
d'euros
sébastien chenu on assiste à une
séquence assez inédite en cette semaine
dans le quinquennat d'emmanuel mâcon
mercredi en début d'après midi à
matignon dit que les mesures présentées
en novembre sont annulées et puis en
début de soirée nouveau communiqué
disant le contraire est ce que ces
atermoiements ces atermoiements sont
pour vous le signe d'un exécutif
déboussolés mais ce sont des amateurs
on nous a vendus pendant la campagne
présidentielle des supers économistes
des experts des gens qui allaient
ringardiser le vieux monde
on allait voir ce qu'on allait voir ce
sont des amateurs le déficit est en
hausse il bricole du soir au matin il
raconte n'importe quoi quand le
président du groupe en marche dès qu'ils
ont été trop intelligent et trop subtile
ils se contredisent d'un jour à l'autre
ils votent ils demandent à ce qu'on vote
contre l'huile de palme alors qu'ils ont
une ministre qui est une lobbyiste de
l'huile de palme qui a défendu l'huile
de palme lorsqu'elle était drh de danone
mais c'est jean lannes
raconte n'importe quoi et en fait les
français sont en train de s'apercevoir
que ces gens là ne font pas de la
politique qui défendent des intérêts oui
ce sont des amateurs est ce que ce ne
sont pas plutôt des experts parce que
cette cette affaire a révélé la
technostructure qui entoure emmanuel
macron et ses experts qui ont pris les
décisions l'exécutif semble sans s'en
rendre compte et appelle à un retour de
la politique
est-ce que ça c'est pas une prise de
conscience salutaire ah oui c'est des
experts ces experts en nullité c'est
désespérant des experts en échec ce sont
des experts comme on en a jamais vu ce
sont même des gagnants j'ai l'impression
non sincèrement ces gens là ne savent
pas gouverner la france
et on se rend compte ça fait un an et
demi on se rencontre emmanuel macron il
est entouré de gens de la
technostructure il est un techno lui ma
ville a jamais mis les pieds sur le
terrain vous savez quand il m'a parlé de
ma circonscription de la ville de denain
madistes une balafre sur le territoire
non c'est la france monsieur le
président oui ce gouvernement est un
gouvernement de techno ils n'ont pas de
conviction ils défendent des intérêts
ils sont à la solde des lobbies
alors il y avait une armée d'ectoplasmes
à l'assemblée nationale ça fait bon je
pense que maintenant tout le monde a
compris que ses députés en marche ne
servait à rien et est incapable de
défendre un amendement est de faire la
pédagogie d'une seule réforme mais en
l'occurrence ce qui s'est passé cette
semaine il a écouté les parlementaires
et maintenant c'est un embrouillamini
incroyable ils se contredisent du soir
au matin ils n'ont pas de ligne
directrice en fait où mène-t-il la
france ou en mène-t-il les français
comment protège-t-il la france comment
protège-t-il notre économie comment
protège-t-il notre identité ou ces
gens-là nous emmène t-il on ne le sait
pas c'est en avant en arrière un pas en
avant deux pas en arrière du soir au
matin
c'est un brouillard ça fait un an et
demi que ça dure et aujourd'hui c'est
devenu visible alors il ya quand même
des avancées dernière minute dans ce
budget on l'a vu un accord a été trouvé
notamment entre l'exécutif et les forces
de l'ordre
il y aura une re leur revalorisation des
salaires est ce que vous pensez que cet
accord va entraîner sorte d'effet boule
de neige qui fait que l'exécutif va
devoir sortir le chéquier maintenant
très souvent de choses nous on demandait
depuis longtemps qu'on rémunère mieux
les forces de l'ordre
donc c'était souhaitable c'était
nécessaire et c'était te descendent mais
encore des millions d'heures
supplémentaires qu'il reste à payer
et puis je vous rappelle que dans le
budget préparé par le ministre de
l'intérieur
les crédits d'équipement du ministère de
l'intérieur cette année sont en baisse
d'ailleurs les équipements de
commissariats moi j'ai un commissariat à
denain quand on voit la façon dont les
dons les dents les forces de leur
travail les conditions à quel travail
c'est scandaleux
oui demain effectivement les
ambulanciers qui sont en souffrance on
est en train dubé risée et paupérisé
l'heure
question les infirmiers libéraux qui
demandent la révision de la nomenclature
de leurs actes ces gens là ont tout à
fait le droit la nécessité et sont dans
leur sont fondés à demander à ce que
aujourd'hui le gouvernement change de
cap mais là encore le gouvernement ne
veut pas de virage social
c'est ce que nous dit edouard philippe
du soir au matin il continue dans le mur
alors les gilets jaunes peut-être sous
d'autres formes on a parlé des
gyrophares bleus
les blouses blanches etc reviendront
alors puisqu'on parle de budget un la
dette approche les 100% du pib le
déficit dépasse les 3% ce que pour vous
face à la crise actuelle il faut le
laisser filer ce déficit
non mais ce déficit cette problématique
c'est la soumission et l'union
européenne
appartement on est soumis à l'union
européenne les 3 % c'est un peu le
plafond de verre c'est l'épée de
damoclès qui risque de vous tomber
dessus si vous les déplacez pas c'est un
choix politique de se soumettre à cela
nous nous considérons que ce n'est pas à
l'europe de nous dicter notre budget
mais nous considérons aussi qu'il y a
des sources d'économies dans ce pays je
vous parlais tout à l'heure des faux
numéro de sécurité sociale ça coûte 20
milliards 1 million de 18 millions un
faux numéro de sécu ça coûte 20
milliards d'euros sur le dos des
français
c'est quand même extrêmement
préoccupante l'évasion fiscale 100
milliards d'euros par an la m1 milliards
d'euros par an men on parle pas de
bricolage n'en parle de ce type de
l'argent parce que ça fait deux fois que
vous nous en parler de chiffres robin
cook est une étude qui est sorti cette
semaine et qui circulent sur laquelle
nous avons demandé d'ailleurs une
commission denquête on a demandé qu'on
puisse se préoccuper de cela pour
justement aller voir si tous ces faux
numéro de sécurité sociale que été
révélée et qui coûterait 20 milliards
d'euros aux français si tout ça une
pertinence et comment on pourrait lutter
contre c'est la fraude sociale
moi je vis je suis député d'une
circonscription à denain on a pu
démanteler parce qu'on a fait pression
j'ai fait pression tant que député sur
les services de l'état pour des ventés
de la fraude sociale on a démantelé 750
dossiers de fraude sociale dans la ville
de denain et rapidement vise à demander
une commission d enquête sur quoi messia
sur la fraude sociale
d'accord alors cette semaine le sénat on
va terminer par sa a remis
le remis sur la table la question des
fichiers s le groupe de travail
sénatorial a été a créé en mai dernier
mais ses conclusions remises cette
semaine se télescope avec l'actualité
l'attentât de strasbourg a relancé la
polémique sur le rôle et l'efficacité de
ces fichiers s mais pour le sénat c'est
néanmoins un instrument à préserver
sandra cerqueira
c'est un système souvent décrié celui
des fichiers est ce l'objectif principal
du rapport du sénat est d'abord de faire
de la pédagogie
parce que chaque attentat relance la
polémique dernier en date celui de
strasbourg il y a une semaine qui a
soulevé une fois de plus des
interrogations sur l'efficacité de ces
fiches
est ce la réalité c'est que la plupart
des gens qui sont dans le fichier s
n'ont pas commis de crime ou de délit
quand je vais c'est sur le marché on dit
mais puisqu'il est fiché est ce pourquoi
vous ne l'avez pas enfermer pour les pas
mis dehors pour qu'ils ne nuisent pas
mais en france il n'existe pas de
détention arbitraire pour être en prison
il faut bien qu'il y ait une décision
d'un juge
une façon de répondre aussi à tous ceux
à droite qui continue de réclamer
l'internement ou l'expulsion des
fichiers est ce le rapporteur françois
pied a tenu à rappeler que la fiche s
est d'abord un motif d' alerte pour les
forces de l'ordre mais qu'elle ne
constituent pas un indicateur de
dangerosité
ni même un outil de suivi de
radicalisation tout ce qui laisse à
penser que peut-être par des solutions
un peu hâtive de port de bracelet
rétention administrative
détention provisoire règlerait le
problème non seulement tron un peu le
peuple par ailleurs le rapport met en
garde contre l'élargissement des
personnes habilitées à consulter les
fiches est ce qui serait risqué sur le
plan opérationnel la fiche est ce fait
partie des 21 une catégorie du fichier
des personnes recherchées qui concerne
toute personne susceptible de troubler
l'ordre public
on en compte plus de 25 mille en france
ça va s'enchaîner on voit que ce rapport
vient rappeler qu'il ne faut pas faire
peut-être des fiches est plus que ne
sont un outil de renseignement
votre parti réclame régulièrement
l'expulsion des fichiers s est rangée
est ce que ce rapport ne vous fait pas
réfléchi alors d'abord monsieur piller
j'étais étonné de son sort à son rapport
puisque il est temps exact contradiction
avec ses propres leaders politiques que
sont invoquées monsieur wauquiez madame
pécresse bon côté c'est pas nouveau chez
les républicains
mais il ya toujours des gens pour un
jour pour nous expliquer que la
tuyauterie n'est pas bonne que ça
explique la nullité l'échec des
politiques menées depuis tant d'années
contre les fiches s
alors moi je vous dire ce qui nous
intéresse ce sont les fichiers est fiché
pour radicalisme
c'est cela qui nous intéresse évidemment
ils sont peu près 21 mille elle en
france fiché pour radicalisme et ce sont
eux qu'il faut surveiller en priorité
et puis si cette tuyauterie deficits ce
n'est pas satisfaisante et bien
améliorons la ya pas de problème de ce
côté là mais il n'empêche qu'au bout du
compte il ya quelqu'un qui affiche
est-ce pour radicalisme et qui n'est pas
français n'a rien à faire sur le
territoire français quelqu'un qui a la
double nationalité doit être déchu de sa
nationalité française et être viré et
puis un français qui est fiché s pour
radicalisme pour salafisme et bien il
doit être immédiatement déférés devant
un tribunal
on a dans le code de krupp procédure
de quoi le déférer de quoi le
sanctionner et probablement de quoi même
l'enfermer donc ce qui nous intéresse ce
sont les 21000 fiche s pour radicalisme
évidemment le type qui est richesse pour
autre chose ce qui n'a rien à voir avec
des possibles attentats nous intéressera
- mais il se trouve que les fiches
est-ce qu'on a vue dernièrement dans les
attentats il était fiche est pour ces
raisons là mais ce que dit ce rapport
c'est que finalement la fiche est sale
et utiles aux services de renseignement
y compris dans les cas de radicalisation
dont vous parlez que l'affichage c'est
bien c'est un petit renseignements épars
casier judiciaire mais bien sûr que
c'est un outil de renseignement mais le
problème c'est qu'on en fait rien après
donc on a un outil de renseignement
il n'y a pas deux il ne prévoit pas de
sanction une
utilisation approfondie après on a
demandé que les richesses puissent être
consultées par les maires on souhaite
qu'un maire sachent ce qu'ils sont c'est
fish s dans sa commune pas pour
l'afficher sur la porte de la mairie
pour le savoir vous savez quand une
famille est défaillante et qu'elle ne
peut pas payer la la cantine le maire
est saisi le ccas est saisi et c'est le
gouvernement nous l'a refusé
ils sont en train d'y revenir ils sont
en train d'y revenir de dire finalement
ce n'était peut-être pas une mauvaise
idée
ils viendront à nos solutions
ils y viendront parce que si l'on veut
se doter réellement d'une politique pour
lutter contre l'islam radical pour
lutter contre les attentats
alors il faut en venir à des solutions
de fermeté et non pas de laxisme et le
rapport pillet est une sorte d' excuses
finalement au désengagement la nullité à
l'incapacité qui a présidé à toutes ces
décisions
merci merci c'est la science younès un
jeune d'avoir été avec nous cette
semaine merci timo merci à la dernière
émission de l'année on se retrouve en
2019 on vous souhaite d'excellentes
fêtes de fin d'année à l'année prochaine
pour une nouvelle année d'actualité
parlementaire
[Musique]